[Music]
morning everybody it's seven o'clock
here in the united kingdom you are very
welcome to spend your breakfast with us
here at sky news this morning will the
supply crisis turn into the grinch that
stole christmas the latest twist in the
story a backlog of containers at a uk
port with vessels being diverted plus a
big day for some of the prickly
post-brexit agreements plenty to ask the
conservative party co-chair oliver
dowden and the shadow of business
secretary ed miliband on today's
programme also this morning as last
night's england game is overshadowed by
a violent clash between hungary fans and
police we will be speaking to the former
england goalkeeper david seaman about
the hopes for the world cup that is at
half past eight and
[Music]
you're gonna need a bigger boat yep
remember sinking your teeth into this
all those years ago we'll speak to the
playwright who's come up with a spin-off
for the west end that's at quarter to
ten it's wednesday the 13th of october
blaming a backlog of threat of delays to
christmas deliveries as a major global
shipping company says it's having to
re-route container ships from felix
stone
is the sausage war sold
will the eu reduce checks on goods
following tensions over the irish sea
border
adapt or die the environment agency says
that places like this could be
underwater unless more is done to stop
climate change
as more crises begin to unfold how young
people in britain are bearing the brunt
of rising living costs
i definitely i'm a bit worried i mean if
we can't just
feel free to you know live a normal life
and then you're worried every second
about how much you'd have to pay it's
not very nice isn't it
and the final frontier star trek actor
william shatner is set to become the
oldest person ever to travel into space
today we report from texas
and fresh evacuations in la palma as the
erupting volcano shows no signs of
simmering
[Music]
morning everybody another supply crisis
blow this morning with a warning of a
threat to christmas deliveries because
of a backlog of shipping containers at
the port of felix stowe mersk says it's
having to divert ships to unload
elsewhere
because of it we're going to be joined
by the conservative party co-chair
shortly first let's take you through the
key developments as we understand them
so far this morning should we felix stow
handles 36 we're told of uk freight and
those are particularly container traffic
shipping company maersk is diverting
cargo to other ports in europe musk says
that ships are waiting at felix's dough
between four and seven days the maersk
boss lars mikhail jensen tells the ft
this morning that retailers may need to
prioritize what they ship over the
christmas period
lots to talk about then uh with the
conservative party co-chair joins us now
mr dowden how's the new job going very
well thank you delighted to be on here
with you yeah time to have a holiday uh
no certainly not since i was uh
appointed chair of the conservative
party um talk about delays at felix
stowe um apparently a third of uk
freight
comes through felix still what's the
problem
well first of all it is worth noting i
believe that felix stokeport authorities
have said this morning that the
situation is improving which is welcome
news there is though clearly a
challenging problem particularly with
hgv drivers and not just here it's
across europe poland u.s even china has
this challenge that's why we've been
taking steps to address it whether it is
for example with more training 5000 more
places for for training hgv drivers
making the process more flexible we're
working through these challenges to
address them and i i know that it's a
difficult and worrying time for for your
viewers and they'll be concerned by
these reports but i want to assure them
and assure you that the government is
very much seized of these challenges and
is getting on with the job of addressing
them
that 5 000 european drivers um how's
that going
well so there's there's two separate
elements so there's 5 000 more
uh training so so getting more people
trained within the uk more places than
training and then there's the further 5
000 visas up in the run-up to christmas
that we've been whether we've made
available i don't have the the latest
numbers to hand for it
27.
well i i'm we may have more updated
numbers than that now it's not going to
be in the hundreds though is that well
it is it is one part of a range of
measures that we are taking so
it's not that is not the only sort of um
thing upon which we're leaving
disappointing
well i'm sure we'll get more more
numbers as as time goes on but that's
why we're not just relying and it's
really important that we don't just rely
on
importing labor as we have done in the
past we also need to make sure we train
up people here in the uk that's why
we're putting the extra resources into
training people up in the uk that's why
i'm making the process better and more
streamlined so there's a range of
measures and it's all about this wider
point which is that we need to get the
skills here have those higher paid jobs
and actually the latest news just
yesterday about increases in wages is a
real example of how that that strategy
is working but the short term impact is
that toys are being turned away for
christmas
well the the situation is uh improving
i'm confident that people will be able
to get their their toys for for
christmas as i say i quite understand
why people are concerned by these
headlines but we are working through
these challenges as we have worked
through other challenges so should
people buy now for christmas just to be
on the safe side i think it's sensible
to to buy when you want some people buy
very early for christmas my wife is
quite an early christmas buyer me too
others buy later i would say just just
buy as as you do normally so for all the
kids watching um obviously father
christmas will be fine and he'll have
everything yes i have i have i have
children myself and uh they can be there
you go dad's reassuring you this morning
kids all's going to be well um the eu
instead let's talk about that the
northern ireland protocol um lots of um
eu concessions we're going to hear more
about that but it's been heavily leaked
in the papers today i'm sure you're well
aware um are the concessions that
they're coming up with enough
well clearly we will we'll wait to
receive the the full um announcement
from the eu uh and i know that lord
frost says he said yesterday uh and the
government as a whole will engage
fully constructively with these
proposals
uh it is important that there is
fundamental change to the the northern
ireland protocol so we'll be looking to
see that but let's see exactly what the
eu comes up with well apparently they
are going to offer a till to remove a
majority of the post-brexit checks on
british goods up to 50
of customs checks on goods will be
lifted more than half of the checks on
meat and plants entering northern
ireland would be abandoned under the new
concessions would that be enough well
those are welcome steps and we will we
will look at them and engage properly
with them but we do need to have a
proper
discussion about this because i think
there are wider questions particularly
in relation to the competence of the the
european court what used to be the ecj
the cgeu
it is a rather anomalous position
whereby
this treaty almost uniquely is governed
by the courts of one party to it but we
knew that already
yes we we knew that and we didn't
highlight it until recently um well well
we knew that originally but i think two
things have have changed uh since then
first of all that was agreed without
knowing what the wider trade
relationship would be with the eu now we
have got a comprehensive trade
arrangement with them and secondly it is
clear that
uh in northern ireland and particularly
in one community in northern ireland the
the northern ireland protocol is not
working and one of the challenges of
that is the fact that the the treaty is
governed by the courts of one of the
signatories so i think we do also need
to engage on that more fundamentally
what do we want that to look like who do
you want to oversee
well there's plenty and again i don't
want to preempt those
discussions but there are there are many
many international treaties that have uh
independent uh
courts and arbitrations uh mechanisms
for them that aren't don't belong to one
party or or the other and i think it's
appropriate that we should engage with
the eu to see how can we can resolve
that because in the end i think the uk
and the eu we surely are united in the
same position which is that we want to
maintain a stability in northern ireland
we want to ensure the continuity of the
belfast agreement and all the other all
the other progress that we've made and
there is a problem with this protocol at
the moment so is it a deal breaker if
the european uh court still has
oversight well it is a it is a major
issue for us and we want to engage them
i'm not going to start
preempting uh you know writing red lines
here here and there but
i think what uh lord frost said
yesterday this was a major issue and we
we do it i mean they've made a lot of
concessions there it would appear i'm
sure that my viewers would think the
same but now you're saying uh it can't
be overseen by the european court so it
does sound as though it's a red line
well
i very much welcome what the said and we
will engage very constructively we'll go
through it in detail i don't know every
element of what the eu are proposing
we've seen some of these reports we also
made clear and lord frost made clear
yesterday consistent with the the
command paper we issued in july that we
also have a challenge with the the way
in which this uh treaty is governed that
the court that has jurisdiction over it
so we'd expect to engage with the eu on
that point as well some say that you are
negotiating we the uk is negotiating in
bad faith
no
quite quite the contrary indeed it has
always been the case that
uh
treaties and agreements are
up for disc further discussion and
further agreement on the move you take
for example the juxtaposed controls uh
in relation to france outreach with with
france on border controls
those have been revised over time and
then dude i believe the french
are seeking again to to change those
this is perfectly normal that we should
seek to adapt and in the end what we
want to do is we want to make sure that
we have something that is enduring that
works for northern ireland and i think
that's a goal that surely both us and
the eu should share oh i'm glad you
brought up the french i hadn't thought
about that um speaking to one of your
colleagues last week about when we're
going to give them the money we owe them
any clearer on that
well we expect the french to to do their
part of the the bargain uh which means
are they not uh well the the um home
secretary has raised concerns about that
and i'm sure the home sector will be
making sure that that is done if the
french keep up there so it's not us
reneging on another deal isn't it no
it's not us reneging on a deal at all
it's making sure that we
deliver on what
uh was agreed originally so we don't
feel we're getting value for money at
the moment so we're not paying them
well the the home secretary has uh
raised concerns about this with her
french opposite numbers and we very much
hope and would expect that we would make
payments as agreed but the french need
to keep up their side of the agreement
so your colleague said to me the other
day that um the payment would be going
through within a matter of weeks that's
not necessarily the case well we we
would very much hope and expect that
would be the case but in return we'd
expect the french to keep up their side
of the agreement okay talk to me about
this um damning report that came out um
yesterday about the government's
handling of the pandemic just to check
first of all you have read it have you
yes of course i've seen you say of
course because of course yesterday the
minister hadn't read it um
are you happy to offer an apology to all
of the families who lost loved ones well
the the prime minister
apologized earlier this year for all the
the hurt and distress that all those
families have have suffered and i
i share that and of course i i offer
that as well it's been a terrible time
for every family affected by this this
terrible
um virus and by the way i welcome this
report as well i think it's a very good
report by um
by greg clark and by by jeremy hunt and
of course the government will as we do
with all these reports
be fully analyzing it and giving a full
response to to the report and all the
recommendations and still looking for
the word story well
the prime minister said sorry and and
are you sorry yes of course i'm sorry as
the prime minister is sorry you i mean i
was just listening to the sort of
experiences
yesterday of those bereaved families and
that kind of terrible loss that they've
suffered and so many people have
suffered not just in this country but
around the world from the covert crisis
what are you sorry about
we're sorry for the the losses that um
that all those families have suffered
but also of course we accept that and i
i hope i think your viewers would
appreciate this as well
during this covert crisis this was an
unprecedented crisis it's a once in a
hundred years um event
there isn't some perfect rule book that
that we could follow we are having to
adapt and move very quickly and of
course we would do some things
differently um with hindsight but also
as the report rightly says and with
things like the vaccine programme um we
made huge progress and and at real pace
with it and mr chair i'm i'm absolutely
confident that my viewers you know and
you had a lot of support at the time it
was a once in a hundred years global
pandemic but
do you appreciate that when ministers
sit there not you but your colleague
yesterday steve barkley sat there and 11
times he refused to apologize that means
that for my viewers that says
politicians are out of touch with the
rest of society
well i i i i said sometimes i'm happy to
say again that i i completely appreciate
and understand the
um the the hurt and the um
the pain that the
families up and down this country have
suffered as a result of
of covert it has been a terrible disease
and um we're still not fully through it
yeah but i i went on to develop the
point which was when ministers sit there
and won't apologize can you understand
that that viewers feel that they're not
in touch with their everyday concerns
well
i understand that uh that your viewers
uh want
uh ministers like me government
ministers to appreciate the the scale of
of of what's happened and the hurt that
they feel and we we do and the prime
minister has has acknowledged that and
has said sorry for all the suffering
that people have and when your
colleagues refuse to apologize 11 times
well well steve said what what steve
said um uh yes then i i'm afraid i
didn't read the the full transcript for
everything that that um that was said in
that particular interview but the prime
minister has has been clear on that he
should have said sorry though
well the prime minister has uh has said
sorry i'm not going to start giving
running commentary on different
interviews that i didn't watch i didn't
know that the future you can't watch the
show sadly
well thank you for joining us hey i
watched you many many times but sadly
yesterday yesterday morning i was unable
to to tune in okay well you can always
watch it back on youtube uh what about
uh your uh successor nadine doris saying
the bbc is impartial is not impartial
well i think this is one of the the big
challenges for the bbc and it it's one
of the things i talked about a lot as
culture secretary with the uh bbc and i
i very much um share nadine's sentiments
that i i love the bbc i genuinely do and
i think the bbc should um
though be a proper national institution
and reflect all parts of the country and
all different um perspectives and
therefore
in order to do that they have to be
impartial they have to reflect not just
the views in london and bristol and
brighton but also the views in dudley
and lee and
wolverhampton or um you know
the north of scotland that's that that
is the role of the bbc to be a genuine
national broadcaster i think they know
that do you think they don't fulfill
that
i think they have acknowledged and if
you look at what tim davey has said
previously he's acknowledged there is a
challenge about making sure the bbc
represents all parts of the united
kingdom all different perspectives and i
think they acknowledge that there's
further to go and i would hope they
continue to do so and what about when
they interview your boss do you think
they're impartial then
i think the bbc needs to strive for
impartiality in all of did you see that
interviews i saw well i think there were
two interviews in question one talking
particularly so i i saw some of both the
the mar interview and listen to some of
the uh nick robinson interviews you
might appreciate as chairman of the
the conservative party i was quite busy
during conference i i thought it was the
curious the way that um
the prime minister was told to stop
talking um but again
go on and on and on it has to be said
well i i'm not i'm not going to get into
the in the sort of the details of each
interview but i think as an overall
point of principle it is really
important that the bbc upholds
impartiality and there are challenges
yeah now i do need to let you go in just
a second but i just want to talk to you
about this report from the
environment agency climate change will
cause more floods and droughts rising
sea levels and a greater demand for
water supplies that according to the
environment agency are we doing enough
to try to stop it uh
we are but there's not much more to do
and this is why the the cop summit the
climate change summit in november is so
essential because
it can't just be the uk alone if we
stopped all our emissions tomorrow it
wouldn't solve climate change that's why
we have to get that international
agreement and the prime minister and
alex sharma who's our special
representative are making good progress
with that and i'm very hopeful that
we'll make progress at the summit but in
addition we need to do things in the uk
in the short run for example that's why
we're investing over five billion pounds
in flood defenses to protect communities
that will be affected before we can get
any wider climate change policies in
place congrats on the new job thanks for
finding the time to come join us
appreciate it thank you thanks a lot
um as we were saying there let's get
some more news on those changes that you
may outline later on to checks on goods
going into northern ireland joining us
is our europe correspondent michelle
clifford hello to michelle tell us more
about what we might be hearing
well the european commission will
publish proposals later we understand to
lift a significant number of checks and
regulations on goods on
medicine on agri-foods also on chilled
meats
going into northern ireland from
great britain and
the
european commission says its proposals
are far-reaching and it's an attempt for
compromise and to break the deadlock
between uh the two sides now the
european commission will clearly be
hoping that this will appease uh the uk
side so that they can make progress uh
lord frost yesterday said um that they
need to consider a new uh protocol that
the current protocol uh simply isn't
working now
even if the proposals uh today are
significant and there are some reports
and suggestions that up to 50 percent of
checks could be lifted there is that
other big issue the issue of the um the
role of the european court of justice as
the final arbiter over the protocol and
lord frost reiterated again yesterday
that that was unacceptable to the united
kingdom now that is uh what we can call
a red line
for the eu we've heard a number of eu
leaders um saying that they cannot see
envisage a scenario
where the ecj would not be governing the
protocol so there's going to be real
difficulty uh there there will be
intense negotiations over the coming
weeks lord frost also issued a threat
yesterday saying that the uk would be
willing to trigger article 16 and that
would um
get rid of some of the terms of the
protocol now then you would be decay
into very dangerous uh territory uh
indeed because that's when you would be
heading for a trade war
okay thanks very much michelle thanks of
course we'll hear more on that later in
the day here on sky news uh quick look
at some of the papers for you this
morning should we be looking like this
on the front of the eye
uh the felix stove story that we've been
focusing on uh the ice says the shipping
company musk is diverting its larger
vessels away from uk ports because of a
backlog of cargo that's waiting to be
processed the ft also pictures the port
of felixstowe which it says is piling up
looking at the metro for unite with the
cabinet office minister steve barclay's
refusal to apologize for what a
parliamentary reporters found were
serious government failings in the early
days of the pandemic just putting that
to the party chair
who said steve said what steve said and
he then went on to apologize personally
mirror leading with boris johnson on
holiday with a picture of the prime
minister painting
i wonder if it's the boss
and this picture caught my eye in the
mail check it out a reminder of how
precarious life is for polar bears
and also um arctic wildlife as ice
continues to disappear at an alarming
rate i have to say it did also remind me
of that fox's uh glacier mint advert
back in the 1980s but just look how
small that area is that polar bear is
managing to just catch a little bit of
sleep on cop26 in november of course and
we will be traveling up to cover that
for you live from glasgow
having a look at the impact of climate
change on the planet and
the top line on our dashboard showing
you how the uk's power is produced that
fossil fuel dependency going up and up
at the moment 56
the number below that is how much warmer
the earth is now than in 1880 when
records first began 1.23 degrees warmer
uh the one belief beneath that is the
time left according to some scientists
that we have to try to keep that level
below 1.5 degrees celsius which some say
is the moment of no return 11 years and
a bit and the scary number at the bottom
that is the millions of tons of co2
emissions
and adapt or die that's the warning from
the environment agency this morning put
that to the minister didn't we which
says we could see more severe flooding
and droughts across england if more
isn't done to defend against extreme
weather brought about by climate change
their new report predicts that england's
winter rainfall will increase six
percent but summer rainfall will be down
15
by the 2050s the agency also warned that
london's sea level is expected to rise
by between 9 to 11 inches by the 2050s
that's a lot isn't it and by the 2080s
london sea level is expected to rise
about
45 centimeters i'm trying to do the math
that's about 18 inches isn't it isn't it
melania is uh down on the river med way
in kent for us this morning hello to
malayna tell us more about this report
good morning kay well climate change may
seem like an abstract concept until it
impacts your home your business your
livelihood and i'm just down the road
from a caravan park which is home to
many people and has been flooded
numerous times over the past years and
with residents having to evacuate and
being left temporarily homeless and this
report warns that we could see more
flooding events like that one in the
future it says there'll be more severe
flooding but there could also be
droughts there's going to be severe
rising of sea levels but also pressure
on the water supply all due to climate
change and in what is perhaps the most
stark warning the report says that we
could see hundreds of people dying due
to severe flooding similarly to what we
saw in germany this year when about 200
people died in sudden floods that really
took the country by surprise now this
tone does seem to be deliberately
alarming in order to shake up decision
makers ahead of the cop 26 climate talks
in glasgow to sort of make them take
some meaningful decisions the agency
says that traditional flood defenses
will no longer be enough and they also
stress is one of the main takeaways that
just trying to prevent greenhouse gases
is no longer enough you have to adapt to
the already inevitable climate changes
that have already happened
thank you
shadow of business secretary and shadow
cop 26 president ed miliband will be
with us this morning that's from five
past eight right here on sky news
half past
half a seven year gonna be speaking to
the immunologist professor dennis
kinnain about reports from some that
their pcr tests are coming back negative
even though lateral flows are positive
quarter eight speaking to road
maintenance directors about potential
snow and ice covered roads this winter
due to a shortage of gritter drivers yep
it's nearly that time
and quarter to nine we're going to be
speaking to former love island
contestant jessica hayes about aftercare
for mothers
who lose a baby
new study has found that young people
despite being financially savvy have
been hit hardest by the increasing cost
of living something made worse by the
pandemic and brady has been speaking to
local people in northampton and has this
report
[Music]
to young people here at northampton
market and they'll tell you that the
only thing that hasn't gone up this year
is their wage packet my wage has been
the same for the last three years but
everything's going up the bills are
going up when i go it's going up and i
end up finding myself i'm not saving no
money i'm stagnant now i'm not going
anywhere so i'm worried about my future
we've got one of the meters you know the
one where you put the sticker and stuff
so uh yeah i guess a lot of time like
you have to sort of worry when you're
gonna put your heating on instead of
just putting on when you're cold i'm not
sure what we'll see this time but i
definitely i'm a bit worried i mean if
we can't just
feel free to you know live a normal life
and then you're worried every second
about how much you'd have to pay it's
not very nice isn't it
dinos vancouver recently launched a
picture framing business in the town and
is watching every penny as he heads
towards what he hopes will be a busy
build up to christmas but he's worried
about rising energy prices
in these days you obviously watch every
every penny where it goes and
obviously it's gonna affect pretty
massively me electric and gas because
yeah past few years the uk
winter
was pretty cold
the report found that young people are
significantly more likely to have fallen
behind on domestic bills and credit card
payments in the last six months than any
other age group it's affecting young
people's financial resilience the
ability of young people to withstand
financial shocks three in ten of them in
the past six months or so have fallen
behind on bills and that's significantly
more than older people so the cost of
living crisis is making it harder for
young people to keep on top of the bills
many young adults faced a difficult
financial situation even before the
pandemic struck culver's impact on the
economy has only served to exacerbate it
ender brady sky news in northampton
to last night's england game now and a
clash that has overshadowed the game
this is what it's looking like hungry uh
police have arrested a fan at wembley
stadium for reportedly racially abusing
a steward it happened during england's
world cup qualifier against hungary last
night which ended in a draw in the
opening minutes violence also broke out
among visiting fans forcing police
officers to retreat down the tunnel
in a statement the met police said
shortly after the start of tonight's
match at wembley officers entered the
stand to arrest a spectator for a
racially aggravated public order offence
following comments made towards a
steward as the officers made the arrests
minor disorder broke out involving other
spectators order was quickly restored
and there have been no further incidents
at this stage
half a state joined by the legendary
england goalkeeper david seaman who will
be discussing last night's game and the
three lions bid for a place in the
2022 world cup
more than 700 residents were ordered to
abandon their homes on tuesday on the
spanish island of la palma as red hot
lava advanced towards their neighborhood
earlier on tuesday officials lifted a
lockdown ordered because of a cloud of
smoke over two villages caused by the
eruption allowing more than 3 000
residents to go outside
lava from the eruption that began on the
19th of september has laid waste to
nearly 600 hectares
in total authorities have said are these
are these live pictures at the moment
natasha no these are not but so we can
here just have a quick listen
have a quick listen to this volcano
it's going to make you very nervous if
you're living on the island isn't it
those poor people so many properties
already having been
destroyed thankfully no reports of any
deaths or major injuries at this stage
now politicians have been talking a lot
recently about the uk shortage of hdv
drivers but it looks as though the
labour leader secured starbuck may be
waiting some time before he's asked to
help behind the wheel take a look at
this
and then when that lines up
was on a visit to oldham uh in greater
manchester yesterday and took a spin in
a lorry but he um crashed the vehicle
while reversing knocking over a metal
fence and was told by his instructor
that he would have
failed
the real test the rhode haulage
association estimates that there are a
hundred thousand lorry driver jobs going
right now not sure that zakir will be
looking for a career change you want to
see it again kosher
no okay revert no okay you've had enough
after that yeah
yeah
good job he has dead with his job at the
cps wasn't it for such a long time
having a quick look at the damage oh
yeah you could t cut that out
now scientists are calling uh for an
urgent investigation after reports of
people testing negative using gold
standard pcr tests we'll talk about that
in just a moment with an immunologist
[Music]
hello again everybody you are watching
the breakfast show here on sky news this
wednesday morning we've had another one
of those government ministers in uh the
studio this morning this time the party
co-chair mr oliver dowden of course and
i put it to him amongst other things
you remember yesterday we had stephen
barclay in the studio and he refused to
apologize 11 times for that uh damning
report remember that
looking into what happened as far as the
pandemic was concerned criticizing
the government he would not say he was
sorry so i was keen to know what the
party chair thought
the prime minister said sorry and and
are you sorry yes of course i'm sorry as
the prime minister is and when your
colleagues refuse to apologize 11 times
well well steve said what what steve
said um uh yes then i i'm afraid i
didn't read the the the full transcript
for everything that that um that was
said in that particular interview but
the prime minister has
has been clear on that
demara's here so they are sorry after
all they are sorry after all yes
obviously an acknowledgement that
yesterday's tone from steve barkley who
when you said
initially do you want to apologize you
said no
we'll learn the lessons of this report
which he said he hadn't read was not the
right tone i think it's worth saying
what oliver dowden the party chairman
has done is he's sounded a lot more
contrite in saying people want to see
government ministers understand the
suffering that they've gone through and
ex and expect the government to show an
appreciation of that and that's what
he's doing he's apologizing for the
suffering that people have gone through
which is
if you could want to be charitable steve
barkley what the prime minister said in
may and perhaps mr barkley was not aware
of that he did later in the day can see
that that was the case oliver dowden is
not apologizing for the failure to lock
down earlier or for any mistakes made in
the government's policy he said
inevitably we would have got things
wrong he's not at this stage apologizing
for those things because the government
are looking to the public inquiry next
year to rattle through all of that but
certainly he's found a much better tone
than steve barkley did yesterday in
terms of saying a lot of people have
suffered and we appreciate that and we
understand the enormity of it and um
what was this turn up as far as northern
ireland was concerning the opening so
we're expecting on northern ireland
today the european commission to respond
to the british side saying this northern
ireland deal which we all signed up to
two years ago is not working by coming
up with new proposals later which we
expect will eliminate a lot of the
checks on goods that uh the uk side say
are making life very difficult for gb
businesses to export to northern ireland
um the eu side say that these are very
far-reaching but we already heard lord
frost yesterday pretty much panning them
before they'd even come out the door
saying actually we're not just concerned
about that we're concerned about the
european court of justice which the
european union says a red line
interestingly oliver dowden did not say
that was a deal breaker it sounded like
perhaps that was the negotiating
starting point but obviously there's a
lot of bad faith here okay tomorrow's
take and nine o'clock this morning
looking forward to it already thanks
very much tomorrow thank you
moving on scientists are calling for an
urgent investigation after reports of
people testing negative using gold
standard pcr tests despite testing
positive on rapid lateral flow tests so
what's going on professor dennis kinnain
immunologist and founding scientist at
signpost diagnostics joining us now
hello to you thanks for joining us on
the program this morning what's
happening
thank you good morning yes um
we we've been we've done approximately
two million uh pcr tests and we've
probably done about 200 to 100 200 000
lateral flow so we we can speak from
experience uh we do not have this
problem at all i mean we see the pcr as
the gold standard as the they go to
when you want to confirm tests it's very
simple to actually um make a lateral
flow positive the school children have
worked out and essentially you can do
that via
you know soft drinks etc and you can
actually change the antibody
configuration to some extent such that
your lateral flow will come up positive
and that's that's that's been known for
a while
okay so what you're saying is um they're
being rigged
no i'm not i'm actually saying that
there are well i mean
they could be in some situations that's
true but what uh typically happens is
that in any test that we have we have a
propensity for false positives false
negatives in um pcr particularly as a
cyprus we do pcrs twice to confirm
positives we don't just uh give a
positive out and invariably our first
result agrees with our second result and
very few false positives indeed and so
what i'm i'm saying is that in any uh
situation in lateral flow for example uh
it's a kind of hair trigger it's
actually something that is actually
easily
let's say um
changeable and given that then you can
get proposed positives as and most
likely in lateral flow actually you're
most likely to get false negatives
lateral flow only picks up very small
and sorry very high amounts of viral
load and is notorious for actually being
insensitive and giving you false
negatives rather than false positives
yeah but but uh my understanding is and
only because i when i had coveted i was
told by the doctor that if if your pc if
your lateral flow test is positive
because it has to have so much um
uh you have to have so much um what's
what's the phrase so much covered in
your body i suppose in order to make it
positive that the likelihood is that you
do have um covid19 absolutely and you
will really see that on the um pcr test
as well you'll see the pcr test is not
either positive or negative a pcr test
will give you a full range
of an indication of the viral load so in
in if you have a positive lateral flow
invariably you'll see a very high peak
on your pcr and this will be confirmed
we never we'd never expect to see
lateral flows picking up positives and i
don't i think there's something uh
either going wrong with the pcr in
question or gone wrong with the lateral
flow here but my in our experiences and
i'm saying we're speaking from
experience at science we've done about
two million pcrs and in addition
hundreds of thousands of lateral flows
we know exactly what to expect and what
we can and definitely the pcr is gold
standard no doubt about it
okay so um the tests are more than
likely wrong that is what you're saying
but i suppose the big question that a
lot of people will have is should they
still self-isolate because they the test
will have registered what it what it did
but they could
potentially still have it i suppose
you're saying not but they're going off
their test results do they self-isolate
i i think you'd trust the the pcr i
think what you uh
with respect to the if you're feeling i
mean
but this winter we see an awful lot of
people with flu coming through and these
people will have many of the symptoms of
covert as you would imagine but these
people once are tested with pcr and
verified as being negative then they can
once they're
feeling better they can actually return
to work
and presume that they had the flu we
also have tests whereby we can actually
test for flu so we can do influenza and
influenza b and other flu viruses and
that's really definitive but the moment
if you're positive with the lateral flow
and you go off and get tested by pcr
then i think you've got to believe the
pcr result and go back to work and
relax about it
okay great advice thanks for joining us
on the programme this morning much
appreciated
thank you
thank you
uh i think half term is just around the
corner isn't it my little boy is much
too big for those sort of things now but
i know a lot of you this morning i'll be
thinking what should we do with the kids
for half time given that so many
countries have come off the red list
what about going to goa
okay well let's take you there for now
we should south africa earlier in the
week didn't we uh nikhil destai is
managing director of goa tourism
development corporation hello thanks for
joining us on the program this morning
why should people go to goa
hello good morning thank you for having
me on your show and uh i'm very happy to
inform you that goa is fully open for
all our vaccinated travelers starting
15th of october the indian government
will start issuing visas for all
tourists who travel by charter flights
and from 15th of november onwards we
will have
visas issued for all those tourists who
arrive by commercial flights as i say
this
goa is fully geared up for welcoming
tourists from all parts of the world
most
especially those from the united kingdom
and um we are hoping for a very
productive tourism season ahead uh in
goa we have had almost 100
double vaccination for all our citizens
and the target is to complete everybody
getting double vaccinated by end of this
month
in addition i'm also very happy to
inform you that in india we will be
administering over 1 billion doses by
end of this week 70 of indians have been
vaccinated with at least one dose so
despite the rough time that we went
through in april and may i'm very happy
to tell you that we have literally
turned the corner and
india is slowly but surely coming back
to normal with covet cases at all time
low i think this is one of the best
time for
vaccinated travelers to come to india
especially goa
most of the activities are fully open
and
all the kovit protocol norms are being
followed and i would
definitely it won't be an exaggeration
if i say that goa
happens to be one of the safest places
on this earth to travel post covet
okay sounds fantastic thank you so much
for taking the time to join us this
morning thank you
thank you very much so you can go to
cape town you can go to goa who knows
who knows where else we might go this
week stay tuned and find out
now william shatner he's going to space
boldly traveling where no 90 year old
has gone before by becoming the oldest
person to venture into space the star
trek actor will be on board jeff bezos's
second blue origin flight with three
others which were launched from a texas
space port as our u.s correspondent greg
milam reports
it's more than 50 years since he boldly
went where no one had gone before that
of course was tv fiction now for real
william shatner will go where certainly
no 90 year old has ever been
and you're going to hear the engine cut
off dressed in the spacesuit of blue
origin the actors completed the final
preparations for a journey that will
treat him to a few minutes of
weightlessness at the edge of space and
the realization of a life's dream i'm
thrilled
and and anxious and a little nervous and
a little uh
uh frightened about this whole new
adventure but i've got to think that
once it's done once i've been into space
and seen
the uh the universe and seeing our earth
and the contrast between that hostility
and this
warmth
and how important it is to keep
the earth alive so that we don't wreck
it
this time the man who as captain kirk
commanded the starship enterprise on our
tv and movie screens won't have to
control anything when the new shepard
rocket blasts off from the texas desert
with him and three others aboard it will
be entirely remote controlled they'll
travel up 66 miles before gently
parachuting back down to earth the whole
thing will last 10 minutes
[Music]
it's been made possible by blue origin
and amazon founder jeff bezos a huge
star trek fan he was the first to enjoy
the experience his billions paid for
back in july and invited shatner to
share it for free
he will be the oldest person ever in
space blue origin says he's met all of
the health and physical requirements to
make a trip to reach as captain kirk
used to say that final frontier greg
milam sky news texas
don't have problems with icy roads do
they in space a warning that uh our
roads could be left covered in dangerous
snow and slippery ice this winter due to
a shortage of gritted drivers speaking
to a road maintenance directly a
director i should say very shortly
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
they have breached the road there is a
lot of gas being fired all around us
[Music]
it is an absolute carnival kind of
atmosphere out here for prime minister
modern decisively
we aim to be the best and most trusted
place for news
[Applause]
the roads have been inundated the only
way out is to get people by boat
what is fear that over 200 people might
have died because of these landslides
[Music]
this on any given day would have been
bustling with people but today it's
absolutely deserted
this is one of the most sensitive areas
of of northeast delhi where there's been
clashes
i'm never lazarus and i'm skies reporter
based in delhi
[Music]
we don't understand that every lake or a
pond is a habitat in itself which houses
frogs snakes crabs turtles birds so many
different life forms
human beings directly depend on
underground water source so a lake or a
pond is necessary to replenish these
groundwater resources
[Music]
did you know that if we all work
together we can really make a difference
to the air pollution around our schools
yeah we should really do that
there'll be a chilly start for some on
wednesday with a grass frost possible in
parts of eastern england
early low cloud and fog will slowly lift
to leave sunny spells for many thicker
clouds over parts of southern and
western britain will be stubborn to
clear giving some patchy light rain in
places
that rain will become increasingly
confined to the northwest during the
afternoon
we've got clean atlantic air moving in
on the westerly flow so the air
pollution index where one means low
pollution and 10 means very high will
stay low everywhere
the air quality report sponsored by
phillips air purifiers
concerns that motorists could be stuck
on icy roads this winter because of a
shortage of gritter lorries let's talk
about it in more detail with ian
morehouse winter maintenance director
for ground control hello to you ian
thanks for joining us how worried are
you
good morning kay
hi where are you good morning kay how
are you today
i'm good thank you i just wondered how
worried you are about not having enough
gritter lorries
uh you know kay we um
of course no we're we're constantly
practicing and preparing for winter you
know that that for us starts back in in
april and we do a lot of work uh to
ensure that our clients who are people
from emergency services through retail
and utilities providers for example
are going to get the service that they
need to keep their sites safe and open
so so we began recruiting uh lorry
drivers for vehicles like the one behind
me in in august to ensure that we had
enough preparation for this winter
okay um how many drivers are you short
or are you pretty confident and also do
you have a problem getting the salt
yeah really great questions uh at the
moment we've got i've actually got a
team of people starting uh today for
inductions i've got about half a dozen
be here today we still got a few
openings and leads um but that's all
about our resilience so everybody
doesn't have to work every evening so
we've got plenty of people today uh to
staff all our roots um and what we're
doing now is adding resilience uh to our
network and we'll continue to do that
throughout the whole winter uh in terms
of uh salt we've got uh i've got about
30 tons behind me i've got about another
80 tons coming here today um but
throughout our entire national network
we've got about 50 000 tons of salt uh
which is more than uh 25 days of salt
usage for our customers so unlike like
the councils we're all preparing uh
throughout the season and making sure
that we've got plenty of salt and
drivers and vehicles to deliver service
okay what's the forecast have you got
one yet
you know i um i was speaking to some of
my colleagues about that yesterday um it
looks like uh october is gonna be uh
probably milder chance of a little bit
more mild than normal though i did hear
some frost in in the forecast that you
just stated there
november again probably very similar to
average um
longer distance
we've been told it might be a very
similar winter to last winter so some of
that high pressure the northerly is
bringing potential some big
cold blasts so like everybody our advice
is to prepare uh be ready for those
conditions and and as individuals you
know when you're out and about if it's
driving whether you're at a car park or
on the roads to be cautious uh you know
take your own uh care and attention
okay and great to talk to you good luck
and thanks very much indeed for joining
us thank you
thank you kay pleasure to be here today
uh thank you um i'm sure that he
wouldn't necessarily want to be
employing sakia's stamina to drive one
of his big lorries for him this is what
he did yesterday when he was in oldham
took a spin in a lorry and then one that
then decided to reverse it here we go
have a look
there you go
okay so over here i thought we were
gonna do a full frame here we are we
missed it um anyway he uh reversed into
a big sign so he's definitely not going
to uh get a job reversing a lorry i
think he's going to be happier anyway
being the uh leader of the opposition
more on that coming up in the next hour
here on sky news all today's top stories
[Music]